foreign
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show we can take a
brief break from talking about tick
tocks to talk about how meta Facebook
we're talking about Facebook I feel like
people still don't even know what you
mean when you say Meta Meta the parent
company of Facebook has been hit with a
record-breaking 1.3 billion dollar fine
over data transfers made to the US by
Facebook this is the largest fine of its
kind and it accompanies an order to stop
data transfers to the United States this
goes back a decade and it goes back to
Revelations about Mass U.S surveillance
so this is actually a little bit of a
complicated story
the fine was from EU Regulators you know
people initially heard this and thought
oh my goodness the US is finding
Facebook for sending data to the US no
the EU is finding Facebook it's actually
1.2 billion Euro which is roughly 1.3
million US Dollars over transfers of
data relating to European citizens to
the United States
some of you may know and we've talked
about this in the context of tick tock
recently
Europe has different rules about data
handling than the US and EU courts
believe that data about European
citizens was transferred to the U.S in
violation of European rules about that
data and it says that the current legal
framework
for data transfers to the U.S does not
address the risks to the fundamental
rights and freedoms of Facebook EU users
that it violates gdpr and it is the
largest data fine of its kind and all of
the data is related to ad targeting
and I mean listen we don't need to get
into the technical details of how the
data was transferred or whatever I think
it's sort of like beyond the scope of
this show and Beyond the political
discussion here but there have been back
and forths about
at one point despite gdpr this type of
data transfer was allowed because of a
transatlantic pact called privacy shield
in 2020 privacy Shield was determined to
be invalid because it didn't protect the
data transferred to the US from then
being scraped by U.S surveillance
program you know it's it's the it's a
mass pad in some total uh but it's a 1.3
billion dollar fine and the question is
are we ever going to get this level of
data protection in the United States
well yeah it's definitely easy to get
lost in the nitty-gritty of this story
but there are experts questioning if
this fine is even going to be enough and
you look at the 1.3 billion dollar
number and you anticipate okay that's
going to be seen as something that can
change the policies over at the company
make them not want to run into the same
mistake again but then if you compare
that to the billions of dollars that
they've been able to make by using this
data in nefarious ways there's all the
reason for them to keep doing what
they're doing and so if we're finally
just getting around now to the EU taking
some action over it are were you to
believe that the executives over at meta
are really worried about the United
States doing anything seeing seeing how
long and drawn out the process has been
and seeing how little the fine has been
compared to how much money they've
clearly made off of this practice I just
don't anticipate anything coming from
the U.S Regulators anytime soon yeah I
don't know that I really do either and I
I really hate that this is just my
perspective but you know I'm a busy guy
big strong guy with tears in my eyes I
I'm busy I have a lot of different
things going on
I completely reject the philosophy of
I'm not doing anything wrong and thus I
don't care about being surveilled I I
reject that completely I think it's so
dangerous as far as policy is concerned
as an individual who relies on these
tools to do what we do I've basically
just given myself over to exactly that
type of ideology but it's not about
doing anything wrong like it's not
criminal concerns it's not Hey listen
I'm not committing crime so I don't it's
more yeah I know that all these
companies they know everything about my
preferences I assume if I email someone
about a flight I'm considering that I
might get ads for that even though I I
don't really know like can the content
of my email be used to Target it I don't
know it's not really clear to me at this
point I I have limits as to how much
time I can put into investigating and
I'm so busy and I got the baby running
around and I'm just kind of like this is
what it is
well it is creepy and there are a lot of
people out there who are just against
this no matter what and they do buy into
this idea that even if you're not doing
anything wrong you have to be concerned
about what different companies have and
I agree when it comes to information
about you there are probably people out
there though who like this sort of thing
who like how ads are targeted to them
specifically based on their search
history and based on other things that
they've looked into maybe even talked
about in conversations we know how
creepy that is when something like that
happens you talk about something with a
friend and then later on you're getting
an ad for that exactly yeah which
supposedly you know whenever whenever
you bring that up someone will go no no
no it's not listening it's because you
probably don't remember but you you
searched for it at some point and it's
like I don't know the conversations are
dead ends yeah and maybe there are
people out there who like that sort of
thing because it makes life easier and
maybe they like the products that they
end up purchasing because of this ad
targeting but the point is that it has
to be done consensually right consumers
need to know what they're getting
themselves into and then you can pick
and choose whether you want to be one of
those people who has their data
harvested in this way yeah and uh I I
don't know what the future in general is
of this sort of discussion Andrew Yang
had the idea of people should be able to
choose to sell their data for some
amount of money I think the problem with
that quite honestly Pat is the the
actual monetary value of any one
person's data if they sold it it feels
like it would be one of those class
action lawsuits where somebody made 500
million but you're eligible for 30 bucks
if you fill out 10 forms and wait a year
I I mean it's is it worth creating an
entire infrastructure for allowing
access to your data for money if it's
going to be 10 bucks I just don't know I
don't know retroactively that would
certainly be a headache but even if we
made that the policy going forward I'm
just wondering how that would all work
like yeah Google be sending you a check
each month I don't know Facebook will be
sending you the check and all these
different sites are compensating you in
some sort of way what are the tax filing
implications that would be such a
nightmare is the is the money you earn
from selling your data taxable that's a
great question uh and can it be
contributed back to a uh carry loss
forward or no okay we're gonna look into
all of it but that's the latest with the
metaphine did you want to add something
else about that was it that was it you
were there okay perfectly let's talk
about Adam Schiff friend of the show oh
what we can now say and former David
Pacman show guest Adam Schiff
is facing a republican attempt to expel
him from Congress
and he is being targeted after the
release of the Durham report which
looked into the investigation into
Trump in Russia
and they want to republicans in Congress
want to expel Adam Schiff
they
um this is I guess you could say it's
being led by this congresswoman Anna
Paulina Luna who said that
um this is the this all reveals the
wrongdoing that Adam Schiff was involved
in he lied to the American people he had
a privileged position on the house
intelligence committee and he pushed
lies about Trump and it made clear that
he and everyone knew it was all a lie
and thus he should be rejected and
expelled from Congress because he was
deliberately dividing the country uh
I've not really seen evidence of that I
have to tell I mean like does it matter
that there's no evidence for what she's
saying well I don't think so because I
think Anna Paulino Luna and these other
Republicans are just trying to get
payback they're trying to treat this as
a Tit for Tat because this took place
around the same time the vote on George
Santos came up about whether he should
be expelled from Congress and the idea
that you can just make this a back and
forth and not take any ownership over
George Santos I find ludicrous like
you're just going to reach into your
back pocket and find some democrat that
you have an issue with and put them up
for expulsion because it's the response
that you feel is appropriate for the
Democrats rightfully going after George
Santos because the Republicans aren't
willing to yeah it's just crazy
especially when you put it into context
of how many representatives over the
years have actually been expelled it's
only been five three of them it was
because they were Confederates during
the Civil War and then two were because
they were criminally charged and didn't
step down of course George Santos I
think fits the bill for someone who's
worthy of expulsion given the countless
lies and now criminal charges that he's
facing the one thing I will say and I'm
trying to confirm this now I think you
can say
um that Adam Schiff throughout different
points in that investigation
did get a little hyperbolic with some of
his predictions and I I I'm not finding
the exact quote here but at some point
I'm pretty sure he said Donald Trump Jr
is going to go to prison that sounds
familiar to me and like that never
seemed likely to me
right if he had just said top aides of
Trump would end up in prison that
actually would have been true because
that was the case when it came to Paul
manafort and Michael Cohen at the time
and and you know others getting charged
at least Roger Stone and Michael Flynn
yeah I I just think that he did listen
Adam Schiff is very good at his job and
separately he's very good at being
interesting in on shows and sometimes uh
you choose being interesting on a show
with something that maybe is a little
much and the whole Don Jr is going to
end up in prison thing I think what was
going overboard that being said he
wasn't making those comments in any way
to suggest he was going to put Junior in
prison like he wasn't saying any
miscarriage of Justice should take place
he was just saying my opinion based on
what I've seen is Don Jr's going down if
he believed that it was wrong that that
isn't ultimately what happened
right and you know he does have some egg
on his face because of that you have to
be sure about that sort of thing before
making a statement like that but I think
just the very fact that Adam Schiff is
on these shows all the time and he's
like a public figure now running for
Senator from California that's why
they're targeting him that's 100 shows
him instead of some other uh person in
Congress because he has the name
recognition because he's trying to seek
at higher office now so they feel like
he's a worthy Target all right so listen
I'm gonna tell you about a story and I
have to use a term that I don't use as a
matter of principle but this is how the
story is being reported and this is how
this is just the way that everybody is
identifying the story well I'm going to
give you the latest news on City bike
Karen okay City bike Karen now I don't
use the now I actually wonder if this
woman's name is actually Karen I don't
believe it is I don't use the term Karen
because I it's a completely racialized
term to refer to white women and so if I
have a policy of not using racialized
terms I've said before Pat I'm not going
to do the whole Karen thing
yep that's true and then there's
sometimes an issue when like there's a
man acting in the form that is often
ascribed to as being a Karen and what do
you call that person it all just gets
very tricky it's best to just avoid the
term altogether I think let's avoid it
forever except right now where I'm going
to tell you that the saga continues with
City bike Karen now let me tell you what
this situation is May 13th so about nine
days ago a video started circulating of
a white woman in New York City
allegedly we have these things called
City bikes in New York the rental bikes
you you undock them you ride and then
you dock it
um a New York City uh white woman tried
to take one of the bikes from a black
youth and it is reported that she used
fake tears as the young cyclist insisted
it was charged on his account she walked
away and her legal team is now fighting
back the legal she has a legal team
that's a story too the legal team says
the video was incomplete
that the woman who's a health care
worker a God on an available bike which
no individuals were on or touching and
paid for it and as she tried to leave
she was confronted by the young people
in the video Someone physically pushed
her bike with her on it back into the
docking station now it is true that when
that happens the bike immediately locks
they blocked her from scanning the code
to rent the bike again
um and that they were physically
intimidating and invisible contact that
she was visibly pregnant and her whole
life is based on helping others
um and that then you know it was she's
essentially the victim uh after the
video went public her employer New York
City Health and Hospital said they've
placed her on leave because the content
is disturbing sort of suggesting that
they believe she is indeed in the wrong
despite what the real story is according
to her lawyer listen I don't really know
you know sometimes we hear Pat it lacks
context right and sometimes we look at
something and we say what could the
context be so sometimes there will be a
an obviously racist statement made like
someone goes all black people should be
killed and they go oh it's lacking
context and we say well the only context
that it could be lacking was that that
was actually a performance as an actor
you know like what what context could
possibly be lacking here
it's hard to believe that the missing
context would make us have the exact
opposite opinion of what happened but at
the same time being placed on leave
based on an incomplete video I don't
know it's just her legal team the videos
viral I I don't know it all just seems
like a mess yeah it's difficult because
we used to think that a video was the
best form of evidence you could really
produce yes it kind of puts you in the
moment you are able to see what's going
on and you don't have to rely on
someone's story as to what took place
you can just watch it but these videos
can be deceiving if they lack the proper
context sometimes you watch a video and
you see everything clearly and that's
all you have to know right like for
example the Derek Chauvin George Floyd
video I think watching that entire thing
made the public realize what was
happening in that instance it's not like
from the trial or anything else we
learned more information that
um Justified what Derek Chauvin did in
that instance but then there's other
examples where you say okay the video
looks damaging I'm thinking about like
maybe the Kyle Rittenhouse case for
example but then as you dig into the
context and the details and the
arguments about self-defense it becomes
a little bit more plausible that uh you
know what took place happened and that
Kyle Rittenhouse was able to get a not
guilty verdict out of that yeah at least
whatever your opinion is about whether
he should have been there you can't help
but see that based on the law there is a
plausible defense to what Kyle
Rittenhouse did and and but again we're
not defending his actions but we're
saying based on the law you start to say
okay I can see how you could end up with
a not guilty verdict here and that was
more context than we saw from just that
video so it makes me think whenever one
of these videos come out and they go
viral should we reserve our judgment how
can we ever be totally sure that we know
enough from just seeing the video it
sometimes takes a little bit longer
because now it sounds like this woman
was actually Vindicated and she was in
the right here based on what we're
seeing and of course more evidence will
probably come out and we can't uh come
down completely determining that she was
in the right here but it does seem like
that following the evidence here do you
don't know the answer to
do you think that because like I've
never been in situations like this you
know I've had situations where it's
tense with an airline worker because of
a canceled flight but there's never even
a chance it'll devolve into this I've
had situations where there's a mentally
ill person either on public transit or
somewhere and it it looks like a
situation that could escalate but it it
doesn't and I like to think that at
least part of it is because of my
behavior which at a certain point will
include removing myself from a situation
do you think that when people get
embroiled in situations like this is it
ever truly
because of nothing they did or are they
in a sense participating to some degree
and and again this isn't it starts to
become like who's the aggressor versus
the victim and could she have just gone
to the next city bike thing but is it
should she leave if she is being
accosted I I just I I don't really know
people and nor have I myself ever been
embroiled in anything like this well
yeah I mean there are cases where people
are specifically targeted and sometimes
those people want to not look like a
pushover and they want to stand their
ground sometimes they do so successfully
and the people move along and find
someone else to Target other times it
escalates so in a situation like this
this woman probably felt that she
rightfully had ownership of the bike to
rent it for that period of time and she
shouldn't have to capitulate to the will
of these people around her and you know
pay for their ride if that's what indeed
they were trying to do to you know get
her to scan the QR code so they could
take the bike for the day if she moves
on to the next bike rack is she like
showing a sign of defeat there I think
maybe just ego plays a big role in this
and that's why people want to stand
their ground when it comes to this stuff
but sometimes that is the right decision
to do other times it is best to just
de-escalate and move on so it's a tricky
thing and it's something you can really
only determine for yourself in the
moment when you when you ended up
kicking that guy in the chest
you weren't looking for trouble that day
no this was entirely in self-defense uh
there was a man hugging my leg while
sitting on the ground of the subway and
uh as we as we know when you're on the
subway going between stations you are
trapped in that moment so I did I did
have uh the right to defend myself and
with one kick to the chest I was able to
subdue the person and the situation get
him rolling off the subway car and I was
not pickpocketed at the end of the day
so I think I handled that situation
successfully but the one thing I don't
remember was
how many seconds would you say went by
Between the kick and the doors opening
at the next station
it was uh it was pretty immediate
um yeah it was like uh maybe as the
station doors were as the car doors were
opening the kick took place oh that
makes it seem a little unnecessary I
have to say but but if he's hugging onto
your legs you couldn't get off I mean I
couldn't really get him yeah yeah yeah
yeah my legs without doing something I
was just imagining like imagine some of
the stops between Manhattan and Brooklyn
it can be like a solid four minutes so
in my head I'm like imagine if the kick
happens 30 seconds in now you've got
three and a half minutes of awkwardness
after you've killed the guy but it
wasn't anything like that that would be
interesting yeah I wonder if people
would be aiding him over in the corner
while he has internal bleeding or
something like that but yeah I wish it
didn't come to this I really wish it
hadn't come to it in Paris that day I
really do but listen Pat was not out
looking for trouble trouble found him
and I think that's the way we sort of
have to leave it at least in retrospect
all right I don't really know how much
that has to do with City bite Karen but
it's always an interesting thing to
bring up that's gonna do it for today
tomorrow there will be more content and
I think for that we can all be glad
[Music]